- [Voiceover] Warning,
if the following video
is relatable to you, you may
be suffering from workaholism.
(slow music)
You work way too much.
You're the first to arrive at the office
and the last to leave.
Work is your happy place.
You come to work even
when you're deathly ill,
indifferent to spreading your
nasty germs to your coworkers.
Your body hates you.
You have no concept of work/life balance.
Your idea of leisure is
watching the occasional episode
of Parks and Recreation before turning in.
- Ha!
- [Voiceover] You always work
when you're not supposed to.
You have neglected all the
relationships in your life,
cancelling plans so you
can get a head start
on next week's work.
Your social life has been diminished
to occasionally liking your
college buddy's Facebook posts.
Let's not even get started
on your dating life,
which is nearly non-existent.
- [Woman] So, what do you do for work?
- Well, I do data analysis.
If you're having fun at work
you never work a day in your life,
and I've been on vacay for five years now,
you hear what I'm saying?
- [Voiceover] Your friends
try to set you up on dates
but you have completely
lost the ability to connect.
- I say data instead of data,
just to pretend like I'm
British or something.
(laughing)
You all right?
Oh man.
- [Voiceover] You just can't stop working.
If you fit into three or
more of these categories
you are officially addicted to work.